I mean people have actually come up to
me after a public talk and as is before
lockdown and one person said to me I
don't get eight hours of sleep am I
going to die and I said well I can
assure you you're going to die but but
it may have nothing to do with your
secretary and so people have become
um frightened about their sleep rather
than embracing the sleep they become
anxious about it there was and it's
reinforced by Sleep apps it's worth
bearing in mind that at the moment No
Sleep apps are endorsed by any of the
sleep federations or FDA approved and of
course you know when you look at the
validation of many of these these apps
you'll go into the paper and you'll see
it work perfectly for eight
undergraduates you know or uh in
California and that's about it but of
course the point I've just made is that
sleep changes as we age and between
individuals and so one algorithm is also
not appropriate for telling us what good
sleep is
um people have come to me and said do
you believe in slow wave sleep and I've
sort of said yes kind of why and they
said well I didn't think I'm getting any
because my app is telling me I don't get
any slow wave sleep and of course these
apps are profoundly they're just they
can't detect that they don't have the
sensitivity to do that and so people can
get very badly misled so there's a sort
of the mantras that are a bit
frustrating you must do this you must do
that but it's reinforced by sleep app
saying we had a good night's sleep or a
bad night's sleep and again we should be
listening to our own biology hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click click here
for the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye